I remember like watching my kids grow up
and again like yes part of their
personality has stayed the same but also
in different phases to their life
they've gone through these dramatically
different types of behaviors and you
know my daughter basically saying
you know basically one kid saying oh I
want the bigger piece the other one's
saying oh everything must be exactly
equal and the third one saying I'm okay
yeah you know I might have to have the
smaller part don't worry about me even
in the early days in the early days of
developed yeah it's just extraordinary
to sort of see these dramatically
different like I mean my wife and I uh
you know are are very different from
each other but we also have you know six
million variants six museums in loci
each if you wish if you just look at
common variant we also have a bunch of
rare variants that are inherited in more
mendelian fashion and now you have you
know an infinite positive number of
possibilities for each of the kids so
basically it's two to the Six Million
Just from the common variance and then
if you like layer in the the rare
variants so let me talk a little bit
about common variance and rare variants
so if you look at this common variants
they're generally weak effect because
selection selects against strong effect
variants so if something like has a big
risk for schizophrenia it won't rise to
high frequency so the ones that are
common are by definition by selection
only the ones that had relatively weak
effect and if all of the variants
associated with personality with
cognition and all aspects of human
behavior where weak effect variants then
kid would basically be just averages of
their parents
if it was like thousands of loci just by
low law of large numbers the average of
two large numbers would be you know very
robustly close to that middle
but what we see is that kids are
dramatically different from each other
so that basically means that in the
context of that common variation you
basically have rare variants that are
inherited in a more mendelian fashion
that basically then sort of govern
likely many different aspects of human
behavior human biology and human
psychology
and that's again like if you look at
sort of a person with schizophrenia
their identical twin
has only 50 chance of actually being
diagnosed with schizophrenia so that
basically means there's probably
developmental
exposures environmental exposures trauma
all kinds of other aspects that can
shape that and if you look at siblings
for the common variance it kind of drops
off exponentially as you would expect
with you know sharing 50 of your genome
25 of your genome you know 12.5 of your
genome Etc with more and more distant
cousins
but the fact that siblings can differ so
much in their personalities that we
observe every day it can't all be
nurture basically you know we we've like
again as parents we we spend enormous
amount of energy trying to fix quote
unquote the nurture part trying to you
know get them to share get them to be
kind get them to be open get them to
trust each other like you know like
overcome the prisoner's dilemma uh of
you know if everyone fans from
themselves we're all going to live in a
horrible place but if we're a little
more altruistic then we're all going to
be in a better place and I think
it's not like we treat our kids
differently but but they're they're just
born differently so in a way as a
geneticist I have to admit that there's
only so much I can do with nurture that
nature definitely plays a big component
the the selection of variants we have
the common variance and the rare
variants
what uh what can we say about the
landscape a possibility they create
if you can just Linger on that so the
the selection of rare variants is divine
how
how do we get the ones that we get is it
just
Laden in that giant evolutionary baggage
so I'm gonna talk about regression why
do we call it regression and
the concept of regression to the mean
the fact that when fighter pilots in a
dogfight did amazingly well they would
give them rewards and then the next time
they're in dogfight they would do worse
so then you know the Navy basically
realized that wow this or at least
interpreted that as wow we're ruining
them by praising them and then they're
going to perform Wars the statistical
interpretation of that is regression of
the mean the fact that you're an
extraordinary pilot you've been trained
in an extraordinary fashion
if that pushes your mean
further and further to extraordinary
achievement
and then in some dogfights you'll just
do extraordinarily well
the probability that the next one will
be just as good is almost nil
because this is the peak of your
performance
and just by statistical odds the next
one will be another sample from the same
underlying distribution which is going
to be a little closer to the mean
so regression analysis takes its name
from this type of realization in the
statistical world now if you now take
um humans you basically have
people who have achieved extraordinary
achievements
uh Einstein for example
you know you would call him for example
the epitome of human intellect
does that mean that all of his children
and grandchildren will be extraordinary
geniuses
probably means that they're sampled from
the same underlying distribution
but he was probably a rare combination
of extremes in addition to these common
variants
so you can basically interpret your kids
variation for example as well of course
they're going to be some kind of sample
from the average of the parents with
some kind of deviation according to the
specific combination of rare variants
that they have that they have inherited
so you know given all that the you know
the possibilities are endless as to sort
of where you should be but you should
always interpret that with well it's
probably an alignment of nature
and nurture and the Nature has both a
common variance that are acting kind of
like the law of large numbers and the
rare variants that are acting more in
the mendelian fashion and then you layer
in the nurture which again in everyday
action we make we shape our future
environment
but the genetics we inherit are shaping
the future environment
of not only us but also our children
so there's this weird nature nurture
interplay and self-reinforcement
where you're kind of shaping your own
environment but you're also shaping the
environment of your kids and your kids
are going to be born in the context of
your environment that you've shaped but
also with a bag of genetic variants that
they have inherited
and there's just so much complexity
associated with that when we start
blaming something on nature it might
just be nurture
it might just be that well yes they
inherited the genes from the parents but
they also you know were shaped by the
same environment so it's very very hard
to untangle the two and you should also
always realize that nature can influence
nurture nurture can influence nature or
at least be correlated with and
predictive of and so on so forth so I
love thinking about that distribution
you mentioned and here's where I can be
my usual ridiculous self
and uh
I sometimes think about that army of
sperm cells
however many hundreds of thousands there
are
and I kind of think of all the
possibilities there
because there's a lot of variation and
one gets to win
is that not a random one it's a totally
ridiculous way to think about no not at
all so I would say evolutionarily we are
a very slow evolving species basically
the generations of humans are a terrible
way to do selection what you need is
processes that allow you to do selection
in a smaller tighter Loop yeah and part
of what
if you look at our immune system for
example
it evolves at a much faster Pace than
humans evolve because there is actually
an evolutionary process that happens
within our immune cells as they're
dividing there's basically vdj
recombination that basically creates
this extraordinary wealth of antibodies
and antigens against the the environment
and basically all these antibodies are
now recognizing of these antigens from
the environment and they
send signals back that cause these cells
that recognize the non-self to multiply
so that basically means that even though
viruses evolve at millions of times
faster than we are
we can still have a component of
ourselves which is environmentally
facing which is sort of evolving at not
the same scale but very rapid pace
sperm expresses perhaps the most
proteins of any cell in the body
and part of the thought is that this
might just be a way to check that the
sperm is intact in other words if you
waited until that human has a liver and
starts eating solid food and you know
sort of filtrates away
you know uh or or kidneys or stomach Etc
basically if you waited until these
mutations you know manifest late late in
life then you would end up not failing
fast and you would end up with a lot of
failed pregnancies and a lot of later
onset you know psychiatric illnesses Etc
If instead you basically Express all of
these genes at the sperm level and if
they misform they basically cause the
sperm to then you have at least
on the male side the ability to exclude
some of those mutations and on the
female side as the egg develops
there's probably a similar process where
you could you could sort of weed out
eggs that are just not you know carrying
beneficial mutations or at least that
are carrying highly detrimentations so
you can basically think of the
evolutionary process in a nested Loop
basically where there's an inner loop
where you get many many more iterations
to to run and then there's an outer loop
that moves at a much slower pace
and going back to uh uh the next step of
evolution of possibly designing systems
that we can use to sort of complement
our own biology or to sort of eradicate
disease and you name it or at least
mitigate some of the I don't know
psychiatric illnesses neurodegenerative
disorders Etc
you can basically and also you know
metabolic immune cancer you name it
simply engineering these mutations from
rational design
might be very inefficient If instead you
have an evolutionary Loop where you're
kind of growing neurons on a dish and
you're exploring evolutionary space and
you're sort of shaping that one protein
to be better adapt that sort of I don't
know recognizing light or permutating
with other neurons Etc you can basically
have a smaller evolutionary Loop that
you can run thousands of times faster
than the speed it would take to evolve
humans for another million years so I
think it's important to think about sort
of this evolvability
as a set of nested structures that allow
you to sort of test many more
combinations but in a more thick setting
yeah that's fascinating the the
mechanism there is uh for sperm to
express proteins to create a testing
ground early on
uh so that the the failed designs don't
make it yeah I mean in design of
Engineering Systems fail fast is one of
the principles you learn like basically
you assert something why do you assert
that because if that something ain't
right you better crash now then sort of
let it cross at an unexpected time
and in a way you can think of it as like
20 000 assert functions assert protein
can fold assert protein can fold and if
any of them fail that sperm is gone well
I just like the fact that I'm the
winning sperm and the results of the
winner winning hashtag winning my wife
always plays me this French song that
actually sings about that it's like you
know remember in life we were all the
first one time
so these once at least one time you were
the first